there's all these kinds of combinations
that seem to be effective when you look
at the statistics and it it seems like
there's maybe it's a scientific way of
thinking but it seems like there is
some conclusion to be drawn there oh
yeah i believe you need to the high
percentage move there's a reason why it
works i think it's
it's made
for a bigger amount of people um
for example i one of my main
strength
athletic strength is i'm an explosive
person so i'll use technique that are
explosive if i get a single leg my my
one of my thing i like to do is to go
for the double power double
but for uh
someone else we got for example in a
single leg position maybe he likes
like buddy troll better he's more a
greco guy like so he or he's a judo guy
he's gonna go for some something else so
but there's move that or i would say
like you just mentioned are universal
like statistically speaking they're
the highest percentage move that works
for pretty much everybody everybody
pretty much put can do a an ada jimmy
you know it's very easy
but it's not everybody that can lock a
triangle with their legs so
so those move like a rear naked choke a
dakar jimmy is the highest percentage
move because it's maybe more accessible
it's accessible for a bigger range yeah
based on the physical characteristics of
the people do you draw on your wisdom
from these high percentages john uh for
like in terms of what to focus on yeah
absolutely um jiu jitsu has an ocean of
moves and you can get lost on that ocean
you can drift for a long period of time
and and end up with very little to show
for it so my whole thing is focus we
only live one lifetime
and your training lifetime is even
shorter than your actual lifetime
so
in that time
i
die
i put a very high
value on
choosing what i believe to be the most
high percentage
uh moves and putting an extraordinary
amount of focus on them
the only problem is that in one
generation a move which can be
considered low percentage might actually
turn out to be high percentage in
another generation for example we talked
earlier about leg locks when i was first
started you said they were considered
the ultimate low percentage move and
a big part of my career has been
convincing people that in fact that was
that was incorrect that they can be a
high percentage move if we just change
our approach to them
um
so we can't just
follow tradition
and say oh this is low percentage this
is a high percentage it has to be part
of
a fairly systematic study where you
investigate
what are the reasons why it's high
percentage or low percentage with
regards takedowns
if you look at what
we can consider the most high percentage
takedowns if you're in front of someone
the single most high percentage way of
taking them down is to get a hold of
both of their legs and push them
backwards
okay if you get a hold of one of their
legs and put a force on them they can
use their other leg to defend themselves
and hop around and funk their way out of
takedowns and cause all kinds of
problems for you i don't care how
athletic your opponent is if you get a
hold of firm grip
of both of his legs and start pushing
him backwards he's going to fall down to
his butt now he might be able to recover
from there but he will fall down
even easier than that is to be behind
someone
take downs for in front of someone are
difficult you go right into their hips
their head their hands you go into all
their defensive weapons if you're
already behind someone and you're doing
what in america they refer to as a matt
return this is significantly easier than
taking someone down from the front
if you have control of their head in a
front headlock position
you've already closed distance on your
opponent you already have close contact
you don't have to worry about shooting
anymore there's no sprawl out of that
you don't have to worry about
guillotines kimuras or the
standard defenses those will
intrinsically be easier takedowns out of
front headlock and so if we're going to
talk about high percentage technique i
always go back to the mechanics of it
rather than just historical tradition
because historical tradition can be
wrong it was wrong about leg locks it
could be wrong about other things too
so my primary thing is okay talk to me
about mechanics
that's what ultimately is going to
determine whether something is high
percentage or not um
gordon pointed out earlier that when
you're behind someone you have innate
physical advantages over the other guy
the human the human body is set up
entirely to
defend threats from the front
we are poorly adapted to defending
threats from the rear we don't have eyes
in the back of our head we can't apply
pushing strength backwards
if you get behind someone takedowns are
ten times easier from behind someone
than they are when you're in front of
someone
if you have to take someone down from
the front get a hold of both of their
legs
if you can get a hold of both of the
legs and are part of pushing force you
will almost always knock them down
if you can get a hold of their head
and work take downs from there again
it's much easier because most of the
defensive apparatus has been taken away
from them before the takedown even
begins and so
for me the most high percentage
takedowns will always be from the front
double legs from any takedown from the
back is going to be significantly easier
than any take down from the front so all
manner of mat return takedowns are going
to be very high percentage
um
and takedowns done out of situations
where the opponent is broken down in
front of you and you have either front
headlock or front chest right position
are going to be significantly easier
than takedowns from the open
of course
you have to consider the full
spectrum of mechanics involved here it's
possible that an outside low single
leading to a double leg is much higher
percentage it's like there's a lot of
chain wrestling yet you know that needs
to be considered as a possibility